you're all invited to a wedding
A Game of Thrones wedding
yes no matter which way you slice it it
seems weddings on this show go about as
well as the time I got married
the sprinklers are going on I'm kidding
I'm horribly single Stephanie please
take me back this video is a deep dive
into episode 5 Game of Thrones lore and
theories on what's to come but don't
worry if you haven't read the book this
is a non-spoiler review I save all those
juicy book and trailer spoilers for my
preview videos so make sure you're
subscribed for when that comes out now
grab your plus one because this is going
to be a wedding to remember gray skies
Mark what's a particularly dark episode
where Northeast of King's Landing at
runestone the home of house Royce lady
Ria Damon's wife affectionately known as
the bronze [ __ ] is out hunting deer
from her interactions with her cousin
Gerald here and later with Damon himself
it seems like an appropriate nickname
especially considering the royces were
known for their bronze armor in the book
Ria Falls from her horse and cracks her
skull on a stone she spends nine days in
bed only to get up and collapse dying an
hour later Damon at this time was still
fighting the hierarchy on Bloodstone so
according to the accounts in Fire and
Blood it couldn't have been him who
murdered Ria now I want your opinion
here did Damon come with the intention
of killing her or did he see an
opportunity and take it let's analyze
the exact order of events see you can
make up your mind it's important to note
here that Ria is the first one to
instigate the chain of events she's the
first one to make a move towards a
weapon in fact demon doesn't even have a
weapon he has to use his Stone you'd
think if he came with the intention of
killing her he'd bring a dagger or
something how tragic would it be if
Damon actually came back to runestone to
try to work things out with his wife
like his brother instructed him to do
but as soon as he got there she just
started bitching him out and he was like
what did you just say you little [ __ ]
the second step is Damon clocks her
reaching for that bow three Ria prepares
to shoot four the horse startles and
five is where things get a bit tricky is
he pushing the horse or merely trying to
steady it to me it doesn't look like
he's pushing the horse at all it was my
interpretation that she's now paralyzed
from this fall which we can see when
Damon pushes his foot against her arm I
do think he was gonna walk away and
leave her there but when she taunts him
saying he can never finish a double
entender because he can't finish with
women nor can he finish her it's what
puts him over the line we never see the
kill but it's heavily implied he's the
one who offter leaving the stone there
to make it look like she bonked her head
the king and raniera traversed this
stormy narrow sea in the hopes of
establishing a marriage with Lord
corliss's son Lenor and the princess
this just goes to show you how desperate
viserys is normally he'd have the
valerians travel to him and they would
be begging for this engagement but
Corliss knows he has the upper hand plus
the king slighted him by choosing
Allison to Wed instead of his daughter
it was rumored last episode that Lena
might wed the Sea Lord of braavos which
would severely diminish the targaryen's
power in the realm and to add insult to
injury no one is there to greet the King
when he arrives he has to make his way
up this giant ass cliff and pass the
Hall of nine basically a giant Hall
honoring the nine great voyages Corliss
undertook which made his house extremely
wealthy on his second voyage Corliss
sailed further east than any westerosi
had ever reached at the time a place by
the name of assai by the shadow so far
east it's not even on the map but back
to the ship where we see the worst job
ever the Royal vomit bucket carrier
beside the king is Lord Lionel strong
who like in the book has been promoted
to hand of the king Otto Hightower as we
know was fired last episode the series
isn't taken to this trip quite well and
the Sea isn't helping his overall health
as Auto Hightower says in the next scene
the king will not live to be an old man
speaking of which Otto and his
contingent of men back at King's Landing
plan to leave the city and make for Old
Town the seat of house Hightower after
is firing it's clear he doesn't want to
be here even if his daughter does not
wish him to go and he flat out accuses
her of being complicit in his
termination his own daughter has chosen
rhaenyra over him in aegon because
Allison doesn't have what it takes to
claim what is hers but all of that is
about to change Allison isn't Gonna Take
It lying down okay maybe I should have
used that clip Otto shouldn't have been
Relentless in his pursuit of seeing
aegon as Heir in fact in the books
that's what leads to Otto being fired
the man just won't shut up harassing the
king about aegon and Otto paints a
pretty Grim picture of what would happen
should rhaenyra Ascend the throne the
realm would not accept a woman as Heir
and houses the targaryens have spurned
such as the Lannisters hightowers and
dondarians would likely revolt we also
learned last episode that the small folk
or common folk don't take to renira that
well either Otto says to her daughter
that to strengthen raniera's claim she
would have to kill Allison and her
children so if you thought tensions
between these two are bad now just you
wait the Royal Carriage the same one we
saw during the Royal hunt makes its way
along the causeway to high tide the seat
of house Valerian on the island of
driftmark when the Waters of Blackwater
Bay are at high tide it cuts the island
off from driftmark proper and that's
likely spicetown below it King viserys
makes his way up this giant cliff and is
like
and let me die at the top of high tide
we see laner Valerian sparring with
Joffrey lawnmouth also known as the
Knight of kisses to the public he is Sir
lenor's friend but they are secret
lovers we also see a much more grown-up
Lana Valerian than when we saw her
almost marry the king in episode 2. okay
we need to talk about this rat Lara
strong and damn does this guy know how
to play the game of Thrones first he
uses the maveo flower as a metaphor for
Allison herself an outsider thriving
among the natives just as this flower
came from outside King's Landing so too
did Alison as she is not a Targaryen by
Blood their talk gets off to an awkward
start lars's father just took over
Allison's father's job but Lars offers
himself as an ally he's pretty
soft-spoken and tends to Mill about in
the background observing something that
makes him a purveyor of Secrets and
gossip this could come in handy remember
he has to sit with the ladies while at
the hunt taking in their rumors as he
enjoyed a delicious cookie manipulating
information for his own personal gain is
what Loris does best he innocently asks
the queen if Rainier is okay he had
heard the night Otto was dismissed at
Grand maester Melos brought the princess
a special T so it must be very serious
but lorus must know that this tea was
concocted as a sort of Plan B and that
the queen was unaware of of its creation
for the queen believed renera when she
vowed on the memory of her mother that
her virginity was still intact but if
Rainier was a virgin why would she be
given this tea this is what Spurs
Allison to question sir Kristen later on
and oh boy we'll get to that so far I'm
giving Loris four Peter baelish's out of
five in the bowels of high tide Elena
and raniera are barred from entering the
meeting between the king and Corliss
it's a physical reminder that she has no
say even in the terms of her marriage
corliss's throne room is adorned with
various Treasures from his voyages and
his throne seems to be crafted from
pieces of Driftwood and what is with
these Kings and their models the award
for most awkward introduction goes to
renice who tries to shake her cousin's
hand forgetting he's lost a few fingers
Lord Corliss is the first to inform the
king of lady Ria Royce's passing a
hunting mishap it was called viserys
finds this rather odd as he's informed
Rio was a fine Rider and he had just
told his brother to go back there to his
wife life this whole event also calls
into question Ria's land because Damon
and Ria had no heirs will her property
pass to Damon later in the episode we'll
hear that after his niece's wedding he
plans to travel to the veil and petition
Lady Jane Aaron for this land you may
have also noticed that this is the first
time the king refuses drink really
pointing out just how sick he really is
we know he's quite the Drinker viserys
has come with the offer of renira's hand
to sir lanor and corliss's balls are so
huge here that instead of immediately
accepting he wants to hammer out some
details what's going on with the
secession and will their grandchildren
take the male heir's last name as his
tradition should rhaenyra and Lenor have
a child there firstborn will sit on the
throne whether they be male or female
renice lets out a little laugh here the
only reason viserys is on the throne in
the first place was that jaharis passed
on her because she was a girl but you
know viserys always down with the
patriarchy of course not when it comes
to matters of your wife giving birth the
last name is also a contentious issue to
which the two come to an agreement Lenor
and Rainier's children will take the
Valerian name but when it comes time to
take the throne they shall become
Targaryen this solidifies that a
Targaryen will always be sitting on the
throne something very important to
viserys who believes aegon's dream that
a Targaryen must be on the throne when
the darkness comes renera takes a stroll
in the beach with her future cousin
husband it's a union neither of them
want they don't hate each other or
anything it's just that they're forced
into this situation against their will
so renyra offers an arrangement
meanwhile at leonor's bachelor party
[Music]
rhaenyra having grown up with Lenor and
presumably having heard the rumors knows
that he prefers men so why not do their
Duty get married and they can see
whoever they want it's an arrangement
Joffrey lawnmau thinks is amazing that
King consort can spend the rest of his
days attending feasts and tournaments
and still get to see him in corliss's
throne room we see crab feeder's mask
which he's taken as a token of Victory
and give it up for Corliss who still
thinks his son is going through a gay
phase he will outgrow it sure Dan three
niece unlike Corliss is very worried
about their son's engagement she knows
that the realm will not allow renera on
that Throne which puts a Target on their
son's back but Corliss tries to quell
his wife's fears merging with the
targaryens would give them the largest
Fleet and half the dragons in the realm
who would dare fight against that
Joffrey swears to be lanor's sworn
protector but he's also curious about
rhaenyra's proposal if the princess
wants this Arrangement there must be
someone in her life she is doing this
for so he makes it his gold to find out
who her mystery Paramore is Rainier
looks out upon the open ocean it's
reminiscent of Luke Skywalker yearning
for a world Beyond his own it's a very
purposeful shot Choice considering what
sir Kristen is about to offer the
princess what if there was a different
path for her one which led to Freedom
where the two of them could travel the
world they'd make their way to sunspear
and onwards to essos where they would
marry not for Crown but for Love
rhaenyra Takes a moment to think she is
the crown and it is her duty to marry a
noble man but this doesn't mean he still
can't be her sworn Knight and have those
sweet bonus perks this is not the answer
Kristen hoped for he already took a risk
by forswearing his kingsguard oath but
now he's being subjugated to nothing but
the princess's [ __ ] something he
thought he could redeem himself from if
the two would marry but Rainier exclaims
that the throne is a larger than her but
sir Kristen has had enough and is like
why won't you
the book offers a similar count of
Kristen professing his love although
this scene takes place in the princess's
bed chamber and not on a boat and this
version Rainier is far more cruel to the
Knight stating that she comes from the
blood of the dragon and he's but a
common cell sword regardless how this
actually transpired one thing is for
certain that quote from that day forward
the love that sir Kristen Cole had
formally born for rhaenyra Targaryen
turned to loathing and disdain and the
man who had hither tube in the
princess's constant companion and
Champion became the most bitter of foes
back at King's Landing Queen Allison
watches the arrival of the king while
he's like I've fallen and I can't get up
but instead of immediately going to the
aid of her husband who her father just
reminded her is not long for this world
she calls in sir Kristen to hopefully
get some more information about rhaenyra
and that specialty sir Lars told her of
after all sir Kristen is rhaenyra's
sworn protector if there's anyone who
knows anything it's him we get a brief
glimpse of Helena here viserys and
Allison's second child as Kristen enters
this deliciously dramatic scene it's set
up perfectly whereby Kristen believes
Allison is questioning him about him and
rhaenyra instead of her and Damon and
that fool just comes clean at telling
the queen that the rumors of rhaenyra's
indiscretion are true and to Allison's
surprise it was him who was involved
this is Allison's proof that rhaenyra
lied to her and on her mother's memory
no less a lie which also led to her
father being fired so if there ever was
a time for Allison to cut things off
with her bestie it's now sir Kristen
only asks for a swift death but to his
surprise Allison releases him in the
king's chambers of viserys's barely
hanging in there I just hope he doesn't
ask for any late night booty calls I
also love how the closer his Valerian
City comes to completion the closer he
comes to death his hand is by his side
and the two have a brief discussion
about his legacy what will viserys be
remembered for he has no conquests nor
defeats is it better to have lived in
peace and be forgotten or die in infamy
and have songs sung after his death it's
one week before the wedding as a host of
Valyrian ships including two dragons sea
smoke and release arrive at King's
Landing this is our first time seeing
meles who is written by rhaenys now in
one of the earlier trailers for the show
they use the exact same shot but with a
huge difference this one has seven
dragons flying around I'm curious why
these showrunners decided to take it out
Harold westerling captain of the
kingsguard has the honor of announcing
all the houses that King has spurned
including the Lannisters and high Towers
notably absent Auto Hightower who's made
his way back to Old Town to add insult
to injury many of these Lords like Jason
Lannister have to congratulate the queen
even though they did not receive her
hand in marriage and don't even make me
bring up his weird comment about women
being late for war Gerald Royce
approaches the king wanting to discuss
the curious case of his cousin's death
but they're interrupted by house
valerian's arrival and poor sir
Christian has to watch as his love
welcomes her future husband Lenor much
to everyone's surprise is the arrival of
Damon who was cast out from King's
Landing at the end of episode 4. now the
king could have him thrown out but it's
the welcome Feast for his daughter's
wedding all the Lords of the realm are
watching and he'd rather not make a
scene but the most badass arrival
belongs to Queen Allison take note of
this green dress as Sir Loris remarks
green is the color of the beacon at Old
Town shines when the high Towers go to
war Allison tells rhaenyra
congratulations
a blessing this is for you but what she
meant to say was right [ __ ]
the welcome Feast commences seven days
of tournaments and feasts which will end
with the royal wedding it's a
particularly gay Affair and no I'm not
just talking about Sir Joffrey checking
out Lenor there are actually so many
moving parts to the scene and different
power dynamics going on between many of
these characters first we have Gerald
confronting Damon but it's going to be
hard to convict the prince as there's no
evidence furthermore after the wedding
demon plans to go to the veil and take
Ria's land second we have this flirty
interaction between Elena and Damon
Damon is a bachelor now after all and
his dancing is about as bad as mine now
a lot of people have been guessing that
this man here is mushroom one of the
largest contributors that's a terrible
pun of accounts found in Fire and Blood
In the book He's a court jester so
there's just not enough information to
back up that this is him at the moment
Joffrey makes quick work surmising that
Ramirez Paramore is none other than her
Sullen sworn Knight sir Kristen and he
makes a hell of a move telling the
Knight to keep Ranier and Lenor safe and
that his secret is safe with him if
you're sir Christian here you gotta be
like ah great now the queen and this
[ __ ] knows a secret that could
potentially get me killed and aren't we
just gonna ignore how viserys eats
there's also a brief dance between
Harwin strong and rhaenyra which ends
with Damon pulling his niece aside and
the two of them speaking in high
Valerian so no one else can understand
them rhaenyra taunts him here why not
just sweep her away to Dragonstone so
the two of them can wed Damon grabs her
here and the king is like what in the
hell but before anything happens
complete pandemonium breaks out now I'm
gonna break down all the little details
here but it's important to note that
this does not happen in the book there
is no welcome Feast brawl and Sir
Joffrey lawn mount's death actually
occurs during one of the tournaments sir
Kristen having not received Rainier's
favor at one of these tournaments like
he did in the first episode makes it his
mission to completely destroy laner's
night killing Joffrey in the process so
we never actually see what started this
brawl whether there were some words
exchanged between Joffrey and Kristen or
if it was unprovoked but think of it
from Sir Kristen's perspective you've
just had the love of your life reject
you you've broken the oath you held so
highly your secret has been found out
and now the queen's future husband's
lover is barking orders about how you
should do your job I'd be pretty pissed
too during the fight laner tries to help
Joffrey but gets socked in the face and
pummeled by other party guests this
brawl isn't just between Joffrey and
Kristen but various houses using it as
an opportunity to release their
frustration to make matters worse the
king's Health worsens this is what
happens when you eat that chicken too
fast one of the more interesting aspects
of this brawl is Lionel strong ordering
his son to do something I wasn't quite
sure if the intention here was to save
renera which he does or to further stoke
the brawl maybe a combination of both
either way this seems to me like a very
calculated move the brawl ends with sir
Kristen having turned Joffrey's face
into a pile of ground beef officially
making this Sir John Joffrey's worst
welcome Feast ever it's interesting that
sir Kristen isn't arrested here being a
member of the King's Guard Hill likely
face some sort of judgment if of course
he doesn't exact judgment on himself the
fact sir Kristen decides to commit
suicide in front of a werewood is
interesting where words are used to Bear
witness to important ceremonies like
marriages or Oaths Jon Snow and Samwell
tarly said their Night's Watch vows in
front of one it is believed that the old
gods watch through the faces of these
trees sir Kristen is stopped by Alison
she knows that he is an honest man and a
good knight and if there is one thing
Allison needs now more than ever is
someone who is honest among the ruined
chaos of the Great Hall rhaenyra and
Lenor are wed in a small ceremony it's
probably a good call considering no one
will likely be in the mood for those
seven days of feast and tourney after
what transpired laner can barely get
through his vows as he's still weeping
over the death of Joffrey and in the
light of the seven the mother father
Warrior Smith Maiden Crone and stranger
the two are wed but if things couldn't
get any worse the king collapses his
crown falling on the ground if that
isn't a metaphor for his imminent demise
but just how much longer will The King
live it's been my understanding that
this is the last episode featuring
Millie Alcock and Emily Carey who play
renera and Alison respectively next
episode they'll be played by their older
counterparts hinting that we'll be
seeing a significant time Jump I haven't
seen the preview yet but I hope to have
a video out on that within the day for
those of you wanting spoilers if you
really want to help me out be sure to
like And subscribe and leave a comment
on what you think is going to happen
next and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
because women will never be ready for
the battle in time